[Applauso]
ciao
[Musica]
la storia che vi voglio raccontare
questa sera comincia in un tardo
pomeriggio d'agosto del 1505 un giovane
sta attraversando un sentiero circondato
dai boschi quando all'improvviso scoppia
un temporale
un fulmine si abbatte su un albero poco
distante il giovane viene sbalzato di
qualche metro e in quei pochi istanti
che gli devono essere sembrati e terni
il giovane è terrorizzato e fa un voto
promette che laddove fosse stata fatta
salva la vita si sarebbe fatto monaco
dopo qualche giorno ritorna ad erfurt la
cittadina dove studia legge e comunica
la sua decisione agli amici ma gli amici
non ci possono credere lui era uno di
quelli sempre pronto a fare festa
amava al canto amava la musica e spesso
lo incontravano per strada agli angoli
dove suonava cantava cercava di
racimolare qualche spicciolo da andare a
spendere in qualche locanda in qualche
taverna il più contrariato dalla
decisione però è il padre carl un uomo
severo ed esigente che aveva immaginato
per il figlio una bella carriera
nell'amministrazione di uno dei nascenti
stati moderni anche il giovane sa di
aver deluso il padre di avergli dato
l'ennesima delusione ma a quel punto non
può tirarsi indietro ha fatto una
promessa il giorno in cui va a bussare
alla porta del monastero agostiniano di
erfurt
con lui ci sono gli amici qualcuno lo
abbraccia qualcun altro lo bacia
qualcun altro ancora piange perché
nessuno di loro puoi immaginare che quel
giovane nato martin lutero lì a poco
avrebbe firmato i suoi scritti come
martin eleutherios martino il liberatore
e martino il liberatore avrebbe causato
nel mondo cattolico una spaccatura
destinata a non saldarsi mai più perché
vi sto raccontando questa storia in una
serata dedicata alla sfida e al
cambiamento
perché la storia il racconto del nostro
passato
questo flusso ininterrotto di eventi che
giunge fino a noi e che ci riguarda
perché la nostra storia perché la storia
del luogo da dove veniamo e la storia di
chi siamo
questo flusso di eventi e permeato da
cambiamenti che sono destinati a segnare
un prima e un dopo
e guardate questi cambiamenti quando non
sono da addebitarsi a cause naturali
sono sempre il frutto dell'azione di
uomini e donne
ho detto uomini e donne non ho detto
eroi e grandi condottieri uomini e donne
che partono dalle proprie fragilità dai
propri vuoti dalle proprie mancanze
dalle proprie debolezze accettano la
sfida del cambiamento e la portano
avanti guardiamo ad esempio martin
lutero
l'abbiamo detto ma non ci dobbiamo
stupire no lui non è un buon monaco
almeno nel senso stretto del termine è
chiaramente per come è arrivato alla
monacazione non è una novità però lutero
ha delle caratteristiche biografiche
caratteriali molto interessanti lui in
una lettera al padre qualche anno dopo
lo scriverà dirà tu vivi ragione e la
mia è stata una scelta impulsiva e
quella di diventare a monaco è stata una
cosa avventata ma io avevo fatto una
promessa e dovevo mantenerla ecco il
primo tratto caratteriale
la consequenzialità la linearità il
secondo tratto caratteriale e la
modestia quando entra monastero martin
lutero lascia gli studi di legge e
intraprende quelli di teologia
diventando professore all'università di
wittenberg e quando scrive un amico dove
si trova questa vita perché scrive si
trova nel culo del mondo proprio così
non vi stupite nemmeno questa volta
perché era questo il modo di parlare di
lutero
ma lui non lo dice con amarezza non è
che vuole diventare professori in
un'importante università tedesca no lui
è così è una persona modesta
e quando gli chiedono ma dove hai
partorito l'elemento essenziale del tuo
pensiero queste idee così rivoluzionarie
lui non risponde nel silenzio di una
biblioteca o in una cattedrale dopo aver
visto la luce aver sentito squilli di
trombe narice al gabinetto desacralizza
ndaw completamente il suo pensiero
l'utero è uno che è lontano dai
protagonismi e lo ripete dice io alla
battaglia di ingegni preferisco
assistere più che partecipare
infine ultimo tratto caratteriale il
senso del dovere e quando diventa
professore all'università di vittime il
suo dovere è quello di leggere e
interpretare le scritture e attraverso
l'interpretazione delle scritture dire
la verità e lui alla ricerca di questa
verità si tormenta perché nelle sacre
scritture cerca anche una risposta ai
suoi problemi di fede quindi alle sue
fragilità quando studia l'utero lo fa in
maniera talmente intensa e talmente
approfondita da notare subito
chiaramente che nella chiesa ci sono
delle cose che non vanno
ma c'è una cosa di cui non riesce a
farsi capace ed è la vendita delle
indulgenze
cos'è successo gli ultimi due papi
giulio ii tra l'altro un uomo violento
tanto nella vita privata quanto in
quella pubblica e leone decimo
provengono nella firenze di banchiere e
sarà per questo che in si ingegnano e
trovano un trucco per spillare soldi
dalle tasche dei fedeli che cosa dicono
il primo peccato quello originale quello
che lo perdoniamo gratis con il
battesimo per tutti gli altri
dovete pagare e allora fa allora
utilizzano una delle più grandi
invenzioni dell'epoca moderna la stampa
a caratteri mobili di gutenberg e si
fanno stampare migliaia e migliaia di
lettere come questa le diffondono in
tutta europa
questa è una lettera di indulgenza il
fedele poteva acquistarla e attraverso
l'acquisto ottenere il perdono di un
peccato
ma dov'è il trucco diventa la più grande
operazione di marketing di tutti i tempi
quando dicono che le lettere di
indulgenze si possono acquistare anche a
favore dei parenti morti perché lì dove
si trovano in purgatorio sicuramente
avrebbero ottenuto uno sconto sulle pene
di cui mondarsi non c'era peccato che
non poteva essere perdonato guardate
l'esempio vero che facevano era questo
qualsiasi peccato
persino una violenza carnale ai danni
della vergine maria
può essere perdonato basta pagare ma
allora questa immagine che vedete qui
dietro di me di lutero con un martello
che affigge le 95 tesi alle porte della
chiesa di vite perché questa cosa qui
pare che non sia mai avvenuta perché
lutero quando pensa al 95 tesi le pensa
come un punto di partenza per una
riflessione da tenersi nell'ambito della
chiesa
tant'è vero che poi redige due lettere
una delle due lettere la invia al suo
vescovo alberto di brandeburgo che non è
proprio uno stinco di santo
quando alberto di brandeburgo riceve la
lettera cosa legge all'interno allora
intanto l'utero non accusa mai la chiesa
lutero mette in dubbio il valore delle
indulgenze e mettendo in dubbio il
valore delle indulgenze mette in dubbio
il potere del papa lutero si chiede ma
se il papa può perdonare i peccati
perché perché torna solo i peccati dei
ricchi di quelli che possono pagare e
non perdona anche i poveri e se può
liberare le anime del purgatorio perché
non le libera tutte e le fa scendere al
paradiso
alberto non ha la preparazione teologica
per discutere con l'utero prende la
lettera la in via roma che sia un
tribunale ecclesiastico a giudicare la
lettera è a punirlo
nel momento in cui in via alla lettera a
roma
la lettera che con le 95 tesi che era
destinata a circolare privatamente
diventa pubblica e tutti vengono a
conoscenza delle tesi di lutero
in quel momento lutero si trova come
l'uomo solo di fronte alla più grande
potenza economica e politica del tempo
guardate la proporzione è esattamente
quella di ciascuno di voi che domani
mattina si trova contro la russia di
putin o la metrica di trump l'utero non
si tira dietro l'utero non può tirarsi
dietro quando viene convocato alla dieta
di worms e l'imperatore idice rinuncia
alle protesi fai un passo indietro e lui
risponde non posso non risponde non
voglio non posso vuol dire io non posso
rinnegare me stesso non posso rinnegare
la mia ricerca della verità
e l'utero diventa l'ercole germanico la
sua immagine
l'immagine di un ragazzo di cui non si
conosceva nemmeno il nome inizia a
circolare in tutta il centro dell'europa
allora nel momento in cui diventa così
forte così conosciuto i suoi detrattori
suoi avversari politici mettono in moto
quella che oggi conosciamo come la
macchina del fango tentano di infangare
la persona per indebolirne il pensiero e
ce lo mostrano così come un monaco
suonato dal demonio come una zampogna ce
lo mostrano con un piccolo diavoletto
che il suo suggeritore occulto
addirittura ci dicono che l'utero è una
delle sette teste dell'apocalisse allora
guardate io a questa storia di lutero
ci ho pensato e ci ho ripensato ma non
tanto in relazione a questo talk ci ho
pensato quando ho cominciato a seguire
una vicenda su internet la televisione
una vicenda che riguardava un individuo
una persona molto distante da lutero e
lo voglio sottolineare subito
io non sto paragonando le due persone io
voglio conservare il senso della
proporzione storica perché la persona di
cui sto parlando
e questa ragazzina grecia tombeur che
cosa fa greta tum berg in occasione
delle elezioni nel suo paese decide di
manifestare quindi prende un cartello e
si fa sedere accanto all'ingresso del
parlamento svedese passano le
televisioni svedesi la inquadrano e
finisce sulle prime pagine dei giornali
su internet sui telegiornali
da lì nelle prime pagine dei giornali di
mezzo mondo
e a quel punto greta tombeur des diventa
la paladina contro i cambiamenti
climatici
la fanno diventare non diventa le stessa
e greta tombeur coglie l'occasione per
raccontare al mondo quello che sta
accadendo quello che prima ha raccontato
dalla svezia adesso lo racconta il mondo
e non si tira indietro
che cosa ci raccontano nel momento in
cui greta diventa così popolare
l'establishment scientifico ci dice che
netta vai a scuola torna a scuola perché
le cose di cui sta parlando
noi dell sappiamo e a me viene in mente
quando un buon anno può carmelitano si
avvicina allo zero gli dice ma tu non
pensi che questa storia la sta prendendo
troppo seriamente rinnega la tua eresia
tanto poi ti lasceranno stare tranquillo
vi rendete conto questa era la chiesa e
questo era lutero questo e
l'establishment scientifico e questa e
greta tombeur ci hanno detto anche che
greta tombeur me lei è così accalorata
per questa questione del clima se la
prende così a cuore perché merita le non
ha ancora altri interessi
noi abbiamo una ragazzina di 16 anni che
viene messa al centro di uno dei più
violenti attacchi sessisti maschilisti
beceri tanto più gravi perché perpretati
ai danni di una ragazzina di 16 anni ci
dicono anche che greta sia manovrata da
una grande potenza economica
in questo caso i rothschild ci dicono
che greta è nelle mani dei democratici
che la muovono come un pupazzo
paragonandolo addirittura l'uso che poi
i nazisti facevano dei ragazzini e
quando non è una potenza economica non è
una potenza politica a muovere greta e
allora sono gli adulti gli adulti in
generale che le stanno rubando
addirittura l'infanzia e poi cosa ci
dicono inoltre ci dicono che lei questa
questione del clima del cambiamento
climatico ce l'ha così a cuore perché
questa sua tenacia discende da una
malattia
lei non è una ragazza consapevole di
quello che fa una ragazza malata e lo
stesso quello che dicevano di lutero
quando un emissario del papa lo incontra
per la prima volta lo guarda poi va via
scrive una lettera a papa e dice ho
incontrato un uomo dagli occhi square se
un uomo con lo sguardo spiritato e
quindi questo la dice lunga su dove da
dove provengono le sue tesi eretiche dal
demonio il possesso demoniaco era
paragonato ad una malattia è quello che
ci dicono di greta le ha una malattia
perciò si comporta in questa maniera e
lei risponde
guardate da una risposta veramente
incredibile
le ci dice quando gli haters guardano
alla tua differenza allora questo vuol
dire che non hanno più nulla in mano
e tu hai vinto asperge power quindi
quello che gli altri pensano che sia in
greto un vulnus una carenza una mancanza
per lei diventa un superpotere io vi
voglio lasciare questa sera con questa
immagine
questa di una barca a vela questa è la
barca a vela che ha condotto greta dalla
gran bretagna agli stati uniti
io su questa barca a vela voglio salire
idealmente e lanciare un messaggio che
un duplice messaggio da un lato mi
rivolgo a chi ha prodotto nella scuola
la marginalizzazione della storia a chi
crede che la storia non sia poi così
importante
allora io voglio dire ok io sono
d'accordo la storia non è maestra di
vita
la storia non ci insegna
non compiere di nuovo gli stessi errori
ma c'è una cosa che la storia ci insegna
il nostro intorno ci aiuta a comprendere
dove eravamo e dove siamo arrivati
la storia ci insegna alla complessità e
in una società che va sempre più verso
la semplificazione la complessità è
tanto più importante
poi mi rivolgo a tutti voi guardate per
quanto piccoli insignificanti sbagliate
vi possiate sentire e proprio in questi
sbagli e proprio in queste mancanze
proprio nelle vostre vulnerabilità che
dovete attingere per dare avvio al
cambiamento
ricordate che una valanga una slavina in
grado di travolgere tutto comincia
sempre con un piccolo fiocco di neve che
per un motivo o per un altro decide di
mettersi a rotolare grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]